hello this is presh talwalkar in this
video i'm going to explain how you can
remove all of the moisturizer or skin
lotion from a bottle
here's a problem you may encounter
you pump and pump
and pump
but none of the moisturizer comes out
while you think the bottle is empty
consumer reports actually weighed what
remains in the bottle and found about 17
to 25 percent still remains
so if you throw away the bottle you're
literally throwing away money
here's how you can get all the
moisturizer out
get a paper towel
a ruler a pair of scissors and we'll
explain how you can buy a cheap plastic
tube
remove the pump and clean off the
moisturizer on the tube so you don't
create a mess
now measure the diameter of the tube
this tube is roughly a quarter inch in
diameter or half a centimeter
and that was the same measurement i got
for all of the major brands
now go to the hardware store and look
for vinyl tubing in the plumbing section
find a tube
that roughly matches the dimensions
this tube has a quarter inch of an inner
diameter
to be sure you can bring your pump to
the store
and make sure the vinyl tube you're
buying fits snugly over the tube from
your moisturizer bottle
the best part is you can buy this vinyl
tubing very cheaply i was able to buy it
by the foot and the entire foot was
about 50 cents
you only need a few inches
for what our purposes are now
so remove about two to three inches
and attach it to the tube from the
moisturizer bottle
you're going to put this back into the
bottle and it'll take a little bit of
effort because you have this extra
tubing that you have to apply pressure
against
but you can squeeze
the hand pump back on
and now you should be able to remove
whatever moisturizer remains using that
extra tube
so this 50 cent fix will save you
several dollars and you can reuse the
tube for every moisturizer bottle
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions on twitter at
preshtalwalker and you can get my books
listed on my website